hi everyone Salan here from Khan Academy
and first of all let me just thank you
for either considering becoming part of
the Learners fund or especially if you
are already a member uh because the
Learners fund really is the backbone of
our philanthropy here at Khan Academy
and we have a big mission as a not
for-profit frankly a big mission for
anyone which is free worldclass
education for anyone anywhere and what I
now sometimes add for folks is the
parenthetical and we're serious about it
it's not just some abstract thing that
we want to put out there but every day
we have a team much more than me uh we
have hundreds of folks directly in under
the employee of Khan Academy about 250
or so folks uh and then there's actually
thousands of people who've volunteered
or are running organizations in other
parts of the world to bring Khan Academy
to more and more and more people and the
way that we envision being able to give
free world-class education to anyone
anywhere is by offering all of the core
academic subjects from prek through the
core of college across all domains uh
you know math science Humanities and
even some things that aren't
traditionally taught in schools things
like financial literacy and maybe
navigating your life but to offer that
to anyone anywhere so this also means
not just in English we're in 50 plus
languages and growing we have people on
the ground in in especially some of the
larger countries that can really benefit
from this and we're being used in some
way shape or form in nearly every
country on the planet and today there's
over 150 million register users and as
far as we've gotten we know that the
potential is for billions of folks to
benefit from the work that we can
together do uh for hopefully generations
to come now the reason why your support
is especially important right now and
why I am especially excited right now is
a lot of yall know that Khan Academy
started in a somewhat organic way my
original background was in in technology
then after business school I found
myself as an analyst at a hedge fund and
I started tutoring cousins and I always
have told the story I started tutoring
naadia she was 12 years old word spreads
in my family free tutoring is going on
and before I know it I'm tutoring 1015
cousins and family friends and the first
KH Academy was me writing exercises for
them online so that they can practice at
their own time and pace and that I as
their tutor their teacher could monitor
uh what they were doing a friend
suggests that I make uh YouTube videos I
initially thought it was a horrible idea
I gave it a shot and that helped us
scale and and reach even more people
many many more people who who weren't my
cousins to the point that in 2008 I set
KH Academy up as a nonprofit 2009 I quit
my day job 2010 we got our first real
funding and that story of tutoring is
especially re relevant now given the
world that we are now entering into if
you think about it everything that KH
Academy has been doing and stands for is
really about scaling personalized
instruction the reason why there's a lot
of evidence evidence uh both uh We've
experienced in our lives but there's
also a lot of research evidence tutoring
works is because it's personalized if a
student hasn't learned something yet a
tutor can keep working with them if a
student is bored and ready to move on a
tutor could do that it can also motivate
and support students in ways that it's
very hard for a teacher in a class of 30
students to do so to a large degree what
we've been doing at Khan Academy is
through interactive exercises and On
Demand video and teacher tools and we've
been working more and more formally with
districts over time we're trying to
bring that level personalization even
when you have one teacher in a class of
30 obviously there's also a lot of folks
just coming on their own uh who might
not have access to certain classes uh
and and and want to tap in or fill in
fill in their gaps and over that time
we've had over 50 plus efficacy studies
that have all pretty much said the same
narrative if students whether inside or
outside of a classroom are able to put
in 30 to 60 Minutes a week of
personalized practice depending on the
study you look at they're going 30 40 50
60 there's even some percentages even
higher than that studies they're
accelerating by by a significant amount
uh which is a big deal in in any
situation there were already far too
many kids who were falling behind even
before the pandemic and we know that
things have gotten even worse and that's
all before you consider what's now
possible with generative AI what we now
believe that Khan Academy is on the cusp
of doing many of y'all might be familiar
with kigo which is uh the generative AI
layer that we've uh built on K Academy
using state-of-the-art AI I know there's
a lot of people talking about this now
but we've been working on this longer
than most and we've been working with
the leading actors with their their
state-of-the-art models is we think
built on the platform that we've already
we already have and the efficacy that we
already have and the distribution to
families and students and districts that
we already have we can get that much
closer using generative AI as a layer on
top of all of that to to getting pretty
close to emulate what I was able to do
with my cousins back then and not just
be a tutor but also be being a teaching
assistant for all the teachers out there
because if we can help them with lesson
planning grading writing progress
reports preparing their own knowledge uh
for for their classes that's more time
and energy that for themselves for their
students and it's more likely that
they're then going to adopt the rest of
Khan Academy for personalized learning
and likewise for the students themselves
they have a question while when they're
watching a video or they want to be
quizzed on something or they want a a
hint not cheating but a hint well then
degenerative AI can help support and
motivate that much more and so I say all
of this uh because none of it would not
be possible uh without your support as I
said at the beginning of this video the
Learners fund really is the backbone of
of the philanthropic support we have at
Khan Academy we are primarily
philanthropically supported so that we
can always have a true north around
what's going to be the best for Learners
and the people who support the Learners
parents and teachers so uh from the
bottom of my heart on behalf of the
entire team at KH Academy but even more
importantly on behalf of today hundreds
of millions of Learners and one day
billions of Learners who are going to
use the resources that you are
supporting I just want to say thank you
because I genuinely think by working
together uh we can make it possible to
have a free world-class education for
anyone anywhere and if you really think
that what that does it almost helps
almost every other issue uh that that
faces us as a civilization so thanks for
being part of this adventure
onward